when it comes to the role of government
i think that's where we sort of disagree
because i think that a lot of this is to
be done
on the social level and and i think that
also how we sort of orient ourselves
toward
the world around us is a really
important thing and and so
one question that i would ask when you
talk about spirituality finding meaning
finding purpose if you go back to sort
of the classical philosophers if you go
back to
aristotle he talks a lot about teleology
he talks about telos the idea that
that using your reason you can discover
telos in the universe natural law that
governs the universe
uh and and what he really means by that
is that if there are certain things that
are designed to achieve certain purposes
then you'll live your happiest life if
you recognize what those are and then
you live
in consonance with that now that can
lead you to some pretty ugly places
depending on
on how rationalistic you get right i
mean aristotle
at the same time that he's promoting the
idea of freedom of rationality is at the
same time promoting the idea that there
are actual hierarchies of human beings
in which some people should be held to
slaves so it's easy to see how this sort
of logic can lead to the wrong places
on the other hand you know the the
attempt to sort of
disconnect the world from any sort of
purpose to disconnect the world from a
teleology
uh also leads to so it leads to the
nihilism and despair that we see so
how do you find the sort of middle
ground in as to what you think
are the rules for the road what do you
think the rules for the road should be
for an individual and what do you think
the rules for the road should be
in terms of a society and then in terms
of government because i think those are
three separate categories and i think
that very often
our mushy sort of political thinking
conflates all three it's like what i
like for individuals is what i also want
a government to do or what i want
society to do is what i want the
government to do and i think it's pretty
important to sort of tease out
what we should expect from each one of
those sort of categories individuals
society and government in these three
areas mate the sort of rules for an
individual the rules for a society and
the rules of a government
yes of course there are like at scale
many simplistic
ideologies begin to warp and break down
and look i'm aware of you and i know
that you're aware of me and we've had a
conversation before
you know and what i feel
is that i would anticipate perhaps
certainly from the comments i get
underneath my own youtube channel
is that a lot of people seem to think
like i'm maybe like a communist or
something
and a communist of course infers a
highly empowered
centralized state and this is not what i
believe in at all
i'm i believe that all of us
are have a right like you know
constitutional thomas paine type
territory
all of us have a right to pursue
happiness and freedom and i don't think
that can be possible under certain
conditions i don't think it can be
impossible if there are if there is the
imposition of unconscious hierarchies i
don't think it can be possible if
there's too much centralized state power
intervening in the lives of
individuals and i don't think it can be
possible anymore
when that we are aware of the variety of
and diversity of ways that there are to
be human
it seems like even when you watch
something from history 100 years ago
there was more tribalization there was
an acceptance of balkanization
separation and i'm like talking about
times that were quite fraught with war
genocide and horror of course
but what we did not have then is this
kind of
uh in a cultural gl and in domed culture
where there is a kind of
a presumed set of morals
ethics and norms that are imposed over
everybody
that the people we're all trying to
appeal to a set of values
that often seem at odds with our
individual freedom
let me put it a little more positively i
feel that there's
so many different ways of being now that
we need to decentralize wherever
possible we need to accept that there
are people that have entirely different
sets of beliefs and values
from one another and just because
they're different it doesn't mean that
they're not right
and i would like you know i'm sure look
me and you could probably get into
arguments about gun control
about pro-life pro-choice about israel
palestine
i'm sure there's so many things that you
and i would argue about and frankly i'd
rather not have those arguments because
i think you're a
very very skilled rhetorician and i
think that when
one is very good at arguing sometimes
you can win arguments without
necessarily being right
and my feeling is that when we are so
different from one another we're gonna
what why are we trying to centralize why
are we trying to create these huge
dominions
when so many varied people are being
asked to deliver homogenized normalized
centralized and ultimately as a result
of that oppressed lifestyle
as an individual i want to be who i am
i've always been sort of a kind of arch
individualist
just by default i want to live in
communities where people share my values
and are there through choice freely i
don't think that we as
essentially evolved advanced enlightened
potentially divine primates
can live in communities of millions
hundreds of thousands
i feel that we should live you know when
we spoke before ben
and you talked about how your orthodox
jewish community is established around a
synagogue around a central set of values
built around family and community and
shared beliefs
of all there's a lot in that there's a
lot in that
and i feel at heart communities
need a shared purpose you know i'm a big
fan of that sebastian younger book reads
the tribe where he talks about the sort
of the experience that service people
have when they come home the loss of
purpose the loss of meaning
because in in our crazy world being in
the military
in the in combat is a closer
approximation of how we evolved to live
than living in a bland
nihilistic urbanized empty hollowed out
culturally vacuous consumerist culture
so you know like we are going to have
weird diverse
varied ways of living and i think that
in a sense i've long fought ben and i
would love your input on this
that we almost don't need i heard a
wonderful quote once um
the world doesn't need more people to
believe in god just
for those of us that do to start acting
like it
and i think that the world doesn't need
new ideas democracy
constitutional rights just these
existing ideas to be lived out correctly
so individuals and freedoms and
societies have a degree of
uh autonomy where possible and an
acceptance that
people are different people have
different values why are we creating all
these hot button points
to quarrel and argue over well if in my
opinion at least
the the dominant problem remains the
same that there's a small strata
of society individuals and institutions
that have uh largesse over the way that
society is organized and most people are
quarreling over crumbs so i again i i
feel that we're
agreeing a lot here because the attempt
to sort of homogenize society and then
demand that everybody lives the same way
i think is really destructive and you
can see it in the united states and this
is one of the reasons why i fear the
idea of a centralized power particularly
in government because government
in my view is essentially a gigantic gun
and basically whoever controls the gun
now controls how everybody else lives
and i prefer the gun basically uh be a
very very
tiny peashooter that is directed in very
specific
directions at people who are attempting
to do active harm to other people
otherwise i don't want that gun to
really be there because i don't want
that gun pointed at me and i don't feel
i should be pointing the gun
at anybody else you know localism and
communitarianism but
in local communities as opposed to
trying to broaden that out universal
in a universalistic fashion uh i think
that that is
one of the answers is the sort of
decentralization that we're that we're
talking about and i think that
you and i agree very much on that thank
you for tuning in to the daily wire one
of the fastest growing conservative
media outlets in the country
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a like and subscribe to our
youtube channel
so you don't miss out on any of our
content